foreign
last spring he played the playoff games for them
Corporal solo moved on Camp Talbot comes in this
is a deep team the LA Kings have really added
I think a lot of depth to their lineup I think
by signing gabrikov and bringing in here Luke
Dubois this is the team that's going to raise
I think a lot of eyebrows around the League
this season a one-year contract coming over
as a free agent in the off-season he's been
really impressive John remember last year
was a shoulder injury that really cost Chase to
Leo the majority of the season there's a break
drops it back to fiala wow that
was benevolent he was in on a break
chose to make the pass Kings with early pressure
in the Anaheim Zone but here was the big stop by
Gibson Dubois got it across to fialo think of
the way that the Colorado Avalanche play that
same style is what Cronin is looking for from the
Ducks Zach Cassian able to set up Adam henrique
in his shot from a sharp angle off the right wing
handled by Talbot now it's the former Winnipeg jet
here Luke Dubois came over in a big off-season
trade pulls up in the neutral zone and takes
it through the logo into the Anaheim zone for
piala on left wing hangs on wraps it up [Music]
see it's about speed on the attack but what
does a good job of gaining the blue line and
a little chip pass sends fiala in he got
Gibson to bite on the short side post to
Gibby good and get across wouldn't it be
interesting if this goes off the stick or
The Escape of Owen Zellweger I think perhaps
it did in between the wickets of John Gibson
playing on the penalty kick well they
want to get the race time and with the
Crackdown I think on obstruction fouls in the
NHL there's more opportunities for them to play
not much that John Gibson can do about
this last season but good cut movement
Irvington just whips it right across the campaign
and as quick as it is on the blade of the stick
he releases that shot John Gibson was hoping
for more help he had 11 a year ago with the
extra man and he's made it two nothing here
Blake lazat takes a hit from Hooters as
he comes across the line and the peace
from with the Finish
Craig for Toronto in the foot and just
kind of lays in behind John Gibson
and it is a tapping it does
not get any easier than that
for grunstrom just sweeps it into a wide open net
finds Andrew agazzino second Tour of Duty
with the Ducks for Andrew luno across the
top mintyakov never afraid to shoot it and Talbot
turns it aside through the screen of Max Jones
ducks with a nice Puck recovery and now they work
from left to right henrique down low popped
into the middle agino a little handcuffed
on the doorstep Jones tries to turn to
his forehand and it's smothered by Talbot
and let's see how this second period unfolds
and if there are more signs of improvement
you know we talk about these young defenses when
we saw nickov moving from Saginaw to Ottawa on
the OHL last season Lewis speeds in on his off
Wing trying to chip it forehand short side little
rebound left laying around and henrique is able to
get there lazat wins the puck mitnikov engages him
swept around right Point Roy sends it
across Cali of high slot never afraid
to shoot the puckets blocked kept in at
the line Du Bois moves it quickly Calia
with a quick shot and Gibson falls to
the ice as he squeezes it yeah good stop
he can zip it down low and then boy
rolling off a hit in front is Calia
quartz to the middle of the ice Leeson breaks
out two on one with Henry takes the shot Pepsi
Talbott score more Zellweger was there on the
doorstep came in but I think Leeson got to
his own rebound yeah I don't know if it if Lee
sin gets to the rebounder if it actually goes
off a king Defender and and slides right
between the pads of the goaltender Talbot
Ducks catch the Kings on a pinch a bad Pinch
at the blue line and the wiggled the ducks on
a 2-1-1 I think it might have gone off
the skate of Mikey Anderson look at it
right here yeah it does and between the pads
in the back of the net anaheim's on the board
but the focus is really on picking your spots
they've been so dominant at the junior level that
they would go go go every single shift and try and
score even when it wasn't the right time to go go
it's not like when players come up from the
American League to the big Club where often
the same system is employed this one's
off the post and out of play favorite
spot on the LA power play which is
you know inside of the Face-Off Dot
the guy his age ducks on the power play now
for the third time as Carlson whips it across
hangs onto it tries to bring it into the
middle looking for vatrano one off a skate
Cassian collects it but it's coughed
up Trevor Moore a short-handed break
Dave Gibson oh grunstrom tripped up by the Toronto
went hard into the boards communication between
Carlson and Zellweger at the Blue Line and in goes
Trevor Moore John Gibson plays it perfectly you
know kind of timed his Retreat into the goal
priest expecting the Moore was going to pull
it to the full forehand side you see Gibson's
right at the top of the blue paint just at the
moment that he releases that little flip shot by
Moore Victor arvidson former Nashville predator
now goes behind the net Kopitar instead out
High campaign shot pass he sends it right back
now into the middle line the Ducks had it for
a moment but not enough to get it past Dowdy
save Gibson as fiala broke his stick and Carrick
clears possible two on one short-handed here's
Lacombe leading the Rush from again that's
off the mask of Talbot with win one a nice
little feat just off to him again and he's
got Talbot beaten on the short side he got
it just under the blocker off the inside
of the post no the other way it's a break
plenty of time left 11 40 third period remains
as England dumps it in oh and Gibson living
right there that almost went off his leg
and into the net many makes a good save
[Music] well that was a chaotic shift England
throws it around the glass it hits one of those
stanchions goes right through the gold priests and
the Ducks never seem to get reorganized after that
runs from shot goes off Gibson and Pops right
up in the air and uh boy arvidson tow picks
loses the puck and at last Anaheim gets it out
a falling Zellweger though unable to change
more right to the goal mouth and it hit
Gibson arbitson was there but in tight
because the final seconds find down here at
crypto Kings get the win but we're not done
I am told that there will be a
shootout at the end of this game